des diplomaties on s'active encore les
américains ont annoncé le déblocage de
100 millions de dollars pour acheminer
en ukraine de nouveau en systèmes anti
char l'idée c'est de continuer à armer
les ukrainiens d'ailleurs une réunion d
affaires des ministres affaires
étrangères des membres de l'otan a lieu
en ce sens ce mercredi bonjour jean
jacques guéry vous êtes à bruxelles la
réunion a commencé à en début d'après
midi où elle commence cet après midi
elle se poursuivra demain durant une
bonne partie de la journée et ne sera
quasiment question que de la guerre en
ukraine le secrétaire général de
l'alliance jens stoltenberg l'a dit hier
le sujet ce sera la fourniture d'armes
aux forces du craignent haine c'est pour
cela que le ministre des affaires
étrangères ukrainien oui trop coulé bas
sera présent lui aussi pour discuter
vraiment des besoins de kiev alors sans
entrer dans les détails jens stoltenberg
a évoqué hier la livraison d'un anti
char ou encore le système de défense
anti-aérien pour cette réunion
stratégique les ministres des affaires
étrangères de la finlande de la suède
ainsi que le chef de la diplomatie
européenne josep borrell ont aussi été
conviés leur pays ne sont pas membres de
l'otan mais ils sont associés aux
réunions depuis le début la crise
ukrainienne et ils seront rejoints par
d'autres états avec la présence des
ministres de géorgie et deux pays d'asie
pacifique comme l'australie le japon la
nouvelle-zélande et la république de
corée cette réunion elle ne peut
évidemment pas s'affranchir du contexte
actuel un celui d'un durcissement
occidentale globale contre la russie
après la révélation des massacres de
boudhha il y a d'abord l'union
européenne qui doit d'évaluer
aujourd'hui ou demain de nouvelles
sanctions contre la russie avec
peut-être un embargo sur le charbon
russe qui représente 45 % des
importations gugnon et ce alors que sur
le plan diplomatique les chancelleries
européennes
exclu à la chaîne les diplomates russes
depuis lundi et déjà on réfléchit à des
mesures supplémentaires tôt ou tard
l'union européenne devra prendre des
sanctions sur le pétrole et le gaz russe
c'est ce qu'a dit d'ailleurs ce matin le
président du conseil européen charles
michel devant les parlementaires
européens réunis à strasbourg aux états
unis vous l'avez dit c'est une aide
supplémentaire à l'ukraine qui a été
débloquée hier une aide qui peut aller
jusqu'à 100 millions de dollars là aussi
pour répondre aux besoins uniques
régnèrent pour des systèmes anti char
bref tout le monde au sein de l'alliance
atlantique du g7 et de l'union
européenne semble aujourd'hui sur la
même longueur d'onde celle d'une
politique et d'une diplomatie plus dur
pour isoler encore un peu plus la russie
merci jean jacques séry depuis